[Music]
hello look at the lobby gamespot's
weekly hungry to be tuesday 2 p.m.
pacific right here on gamespot com i'm
your host on you to our joint as ever by
mr. christopher waters Danny hello I'm
doing great that's a great t-shirt man i
gotta say thank you you're up in your
t-shirt game a little bit thank you and
I appreciate one more t shirt confirmed
its cost 25 dogs more than the game
apartment small-batch t-shirts are
expected to produce and then ship its
own beds John them outside of the the US
as it turns out yeah very difficult
that's something you guys learn the hard
way Jeff Gerstmann from jon bon bon all
night and I dibalans here what's up Andy
I want to talk to you about cars yeah I
got a car project cars Oh CD Projekt
cars yeah it's a you have a CD player in
your car mm-hmm a six changer being that
do you really yeah and the trot is
definitely two CDs taylor swift and
beastie boobs real ends of the gangs
back down there yeah good do you a CD
player in you uh yeah might actually
play dvds only when the cars in park so
it's useless is there like a wire you
can like classf it yeah there's there's
a box you can install that like you know
when you hit the button on the steering
wheel you can kind of toggle it too
great i keep thinking about going that
blow into it and it doesn't yeah i just
as a callow it's like you're not drunk
you can watch this DVD through in here
great those features are that's one of
the many features in project cars the
game that came out this week watching
DVDs it's not unfortunately this week on
consoles past week on pc yes and that
was for early access unless you're
outside the US and i think it came out
for everywhere for everyone last week
it's very confusing yeah this is a
confusing game a first encounter a solid
recon what this car is down for hello uh
[ __ ] I don't know you said minutes
before the show careening around racing
spaces ass racing enthusiast customized
community assists project racer simulate
a go it was bait and how much project
cars have you played Joe yeah not that
much not that much we did a little bit
of coverage on it I mess with it a
little bit more on the pc and then i've
got an xbox one copy that i keep me in
to check out just kind of curious to see
how like it stacks up
two forts on forces platform is that
what you feel like it's like the biggest
comparison to so yes but only in the
sense that i am playing it with a
gamepad where I mean obviously you know
it has support it'll you can go down the
rabbit hole with this thing with you
know track I our support and all those
sort of stuff if you're like a nutjob it
don't buy a racing wheel you've got a
gamepad what about that game pad racing
wheel that Microsoft oh the wireless
like the you force forwarded yeah like
that nightmarish boomerang yeah I have
one of those it's dumb of course yeah
yeah enough or so so yeah from from my
perspective like you know you can turn
on the assist turn off the assists you
know it's a similar you know they're
going for realism I think they'll go
more real than fortson and oh yeah oh
yeah su if you want to go down that hole
but for me the sweet spot is to make
this a Fortesque game yeah I wasn't sure
cuz God like car games have become so
granular and like what's real and what's
Arkady like before it was kind of like
this is a simulation game and it's Gran
Turismo and then this is let us just
like you don't know can you launch
things out of your car is it on fire
most the time he's going on or in terms
of this one it's like you can do stuff
like you're like you can check your fuel
like make sure you're like you're taking
certain me a few all I'm like chair
where and pit strategies like it gets
scary fast it kind of when they were
because this games been around for a
long time and obviously it was sort of
crazy it kind of felt like I said I
always say or factors yeah yeah like a
felt like this sort of community made
we're gonna make the simulator for
people who care about ours guy like this
way and and it kind of does get that way
I'm thing with a steering wheel at the
moment so I'm having a completely
different experience right you're not
totally yeah okay like I'm pond like
racing form of a cars around spa and
like changing gears is like you know
creating wheel spin and it's it's making
me like engage with on that level right
and you're playing on the controller
you're doing the video review yeah at
the moment how are you enjoying it so
I'm like we said about playing it
comparatively two forts up it's like I
think I wanted to see what it would be
like on ps4 because I think there's a
vacuum for this game absolutely I'm
people's for like really like driveclub
just dropped it and yeah
so this comes in phils that that nicely
but it is super race it's like a race
simulator has the name racist it's a
very racist it's like didn't get that
far yeah so if you want to do a weekend
that you know Sonoma Raceway like and
have everything you have a practice
round have a second front wall so out of
the pit and then like lineup do race and
man this game is perfect for that but
it's it's not necessarily about like
enjoying driving or like enjoying cars
so it's a it's not about Cara passion
and no it's it's so not about car
passion it's funny sour here's my
favorite game like look at the things I
guess is that it's all been of all about
the unlocks like it's been about like
unraveling this game and like buy cars
and yeah get new liveries and
customizing let you put a whole other
engine in the car and we'll see you next
see what happens with you know like it's
about structure in its its progression
and stuff right well yeah you think
about forts uh you know it will serve up
whatever you want it like if you if you
decide you want to take on another car
it's got stuff for that that seems
custom tailored for that where is
project cars is just kind of it's a
toolbox all right i mean you there's
there's a progression to the career mode
you can get in there and kind of advance
and get from one year to the next but
even in xiamen teams but it's not you
can start yeah we are you going to start
at the top it's crazy like even in that
they're like you doesn't force you to go
into cards right you could just straight
up like the carts i started yeah i
started a career cards and it's who i
was frustrated for a second but then I
felt like the sense of speed was there
where it wasn't in like the GT races
okay and it was real a lot of fun to
like get those down and then switching
back to like a mustang GT race I
couldn't drive it like it was it felt
like it was going 10 miles an hour buys
more like 100 and I was just like yeah
all over the track I couldn't get it
under control so it's like there's a
huge learning curve with project cars
and I guess that's my question with any
sort of simulation like this that goes
on such a such a deep dive and allows to
for such a like you know rigorously
tested and like this high skill ceiling
you know learning it getting past these
difficulty markers learning stuff that's
the satisfaction of playing a game but
once you sort of you top out in like you
nail a race like
does it ever sort of ceiling or you know
or is it like there's always new stuff
to do there's always new challenges to
master and there's always satisfaction
to be found I think that's going to come
from the player you know and what you
kind of bring to it cuz i think at some
point you know if you're if you're
engaging with this to the fullest at
some point you up start asking yourself
why am i not playing i racing well why
am i not going all the way and I racing
I don't think is this prettiest project
car but you know like I racing is for
lunatics and and you know that stuff is
out there if you want to go all the way
with it and project cars I don't think
goes quite that far but I think it has a
wide range of play styles so that it can
support yeah so if you do want to have
that gamepad experience that you know I
think it's a totally viable cop yeah I
have actually seen it on consoles the
performance I've been playing yeah pc
like it looks really awesome yeah it's a
fantastic looking game but yeah totally
like that's the the ps4 thing is
especially apt because I think because
who cares about trot close yeah exactly
I think well you're saying cuz like it's
so it is really deep so like you can
spend all your time learning one car
right yeah and then you race it and then
there's like a lot of tracks you have to
know the tracks so then you have to
learn treks and then it's like okay then
you start tuning the car you like wanna
you know switch your tire pressure a
little bit which the ride height a
little bit to be like oh that one corner
gives me trouble I gotta stabilize my
car stiffen it out you know get around
there and then you can you can even go
so far into like okay I need less fuel
for this race so at the end of the race
I'll be lighter than the guy next to me
so we're neck and neck and I pull it
it's like that's so crazy and it's like
all that stuff is open as well so it's
not like just do it the thing i didn't
like I guess would 42 games or
especially horizon I guess maybe that's
not a fair comparison is that your
unlocking everything and what I'd always
like to bet say I played on the f1 games
and I just like going in picking a like
a combination of stuff that I'm into and
just like spending two hours playing
that yeah so like this seems like really
well structure for that so yeah I mean
horizons like a different kind of game I
mean that's all right at that point in
you know that might as well be need for
speed or something yeah it's so
different oh yeah no source better need
for speed hold on oh right into the
European stuff I thought it was not as
cool as rough like we are yours your
hatred of Europe as well
story Jeff yeah not totally have any you
guys played online well I tried a little
bit that count you know it was so good
you know it was a game that had like
forced cockpit view a great assistance
any other stuff so it's like three
practice things yes spin out just tore
cantorial ah crap and then I quit the
model inside yeah Charlie after that
apparently the online is where I guess
that's kind of where the iRacing stuff
comes in as well like that's where the
real competitive nature sure yeah the AI
in this kind of seems real dumb in a way
that I kind of appreciate because the
like battling the car seems to be where
the difficulties otter yeah yeah like I
almost like get a satisfaction from just
racing kind of dumb AI like apple thing
up to like 80 about 100 I was great to
the point where like I'll spin out but
then I know I actually probably catch up
with them again it's not like because
there's no replays right yeah mines man
yeah yeah it's a game for a very
specific type of person I think it as
much as it you can even adjust it to be
more forts alike and maybe a little bit
easier than that force you can get but
yeah it is still kind of unforgiving in
some ways that like I think on consoles
where people are used to things like
rewind and yeah you know like Need for
Speed game and stuff like that they
might just look at this go die this is
too much for me but yeah it's it's cool
and a quick look up on giant bomb yeah
cool and the review will be up on
gamespot if it's not up what is probably
going live any men pretty 6 we're behind
on this one but we'll do a bay review
today yeah she'll be up to there
tomorrow right awesome
[Music]
you